hi guys welcome to the just pearly songs
youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to king
von took her to the o
as usual don't forget to subscribe
subscribe
subscribe i'm trying to move out of my
parents house and the more subscribers i
have
the better on top of that don't forget
to leave a comment
leave a like comment did i get the
analysis right
did i not get it right i don't know let
me know
oh and by the way don't forget subscribe
to my instagram
i do submissions and polls on my
instagram
the links in the bio i have some cool
pictures
where i have some cool outfits that too
but most importantly you can do song
submissions and instagram
polls for what song i should react to
next
mr vaughn you've been coming here for
four weeks and you've got to tell me
nothing
it's now or never never
he's got a lawyer for what
[Music]
she means business he's just got stacks
of cash
[Music]
okay so he says i just got some top
from this stripper he called her a [ __ ]
i think he should have said a girl that
would have been nicer but
it seems like the store is like popping
because in his last song
he talked about the store too so lots of
women he meets there
and this girl happened to be a stripper
you know no shame in that
and yeah hit it off got some oral
intercourse
[Music]
she don't know that she left a person
named sure you know wanna play we can go
down first
[Music]
okay so it looks like i don't know what
the o
is but it looks like he's taken the
stripper to the oh it could be chicago
i don't know what o stands for on top of
that he brought her somewhere i think to
get some weed
and then dropped her off said you know
what you got two minutes
otherwise you got to call yourself a
lift king von is
not trying to waste any time
and i see a truck it's just pulling up
someone i'm not a big goofy [ __ ] he
trying to look tough i'm like what what
are you trying
[Music]
[Music]
okay so it looks like she left your
phone in the car
okay and
then this random dude comes up and is
like it looks like they're getting into
a fight
and von is telling his lawyer about this
um i guess the guy's named
duck that's a weird name but you know
how cold
i still got her phone she's taking too
long she runs in my car so i hit the
[Music]
left
okay so the girl that was rude
so this man comes up and he's like
yelling at the stripper
and then king von is like nah i'm not
trying to deal with that
so he's like
he's like nah nah
and then this other guy gets a brick and
throws it through his car
so king vaughn takes his gun and shoots
twice oh and he hit him he did hit him
okay
nick dude cause this don't make the news
gotta make your move hold that [ __ ]
cause she looking confused broke the
rules cause this [ __ ]
plus i just popped through but she ain't
crying but this whole smelling and this
[ __ ] looking
out
[Music]
okay what is 63rd like
i don't understand like is there
something wrong
with 63rd street like a 62nd street
better i'm just asking the tough
questions here
on top of that he just locked this girl
out of his car
shot her axe it seems like
and then she gets back in the car and is
like you know what
let's let bygones be bygones it's cool
and now they're going to get food and he
only let her in the car
because she's a witness like ladies
you deserve better than this um
[Music]
oh
what is the oh that is the biggest
question i have
i took her to the oh is that where you
buy drugs that wouldn't make sense like
this just leaves a lot of room for
interpretation
oh wow the lawyer's getting kind of into
it
i'm a fan of king ron i always think
his music is catchy and it tells a story
which i think is cool
however i have a couple complaints
what is the o if i knew what the o was
the story would make a lot more sense
that's my biggest complaint what is the
oh
and then the lawyer like she's like
chilling like you know how it goes
lady you don't know how it goes like i
took like
why is he saying what did he say he said
i want to help but this ain't my hoe you
know how it goes
this [ __ ] a hoe met her at the stow you
know how it goes
but you don't the lawyer like
that lady was the whitest lady ever she
did not
she did not know how to go you know just
like
i don't know how that goes you think i
know what it's like to meet a hoe
at the store that's a stripper and just
like
hang out have a shootout and then go get
food
and tell your lawyer about it
i don't know how that goes anyways let
me know did i get this interpretation
right
wrong do i need to improve my
interpretation skills
let me know in the comments on top of
that don't forget to subscribe
i'm going to do something fun at 20 000
subscribers i don't know what yet
but maybe i'll react to 300 dead ops and
leave a like
on the video while you're at it you
already left a comment
and you subscribed just do that too
i'mma talk to you guys next time